a votar todos eles mas a crescer e foi
por este convite é mesmo muito bom estar
de volta popular não tem esta sala que
eu não quero finalizar ele não estava
assim tanto mas tanto é um caos político
e eu em curso em 2013 é conceito da fifa
ainda em 2010 por isso não foi assim há
tanto tempo que que abandonou esta foi
colar passaram três anos em maio e
durante três anos e meio estou agora na
minha experiência profissional e já tive
duas experiências e se me querem fora da
caixa que mais chamava acho que hoje vou
falar aqui hoje eu estava a pensar em
pôr com uma amiga também começamos a
pensar que quando são de clientes papo
pra falar em infantários propõe ensino
básico e ensino secundário popular
formulada e nós queremos o nosso curso e
depois vamos trabalhar esta é um curso
normal das coisas e foi também no meu é
sempre uma pessoa umas tentativas sempre
tive aquela insatisfação constante
crescendo fazer mais e ir em frente e
crescente estádio em novas coisas e
também não sei por que isso aconteceu
fez parte da pj que ontem foi uma
experiência fantástica e muito bem que
ela também incentivando envolvida na
ponta dante que com muita felicidade
conseguiram ser tão antes nada foi
apenas minha empresa e no decurso destas
das linhas envolvidas também surgiu o
compacto da muda para você e eu comecei
o comportamento com eles fiquem fiquei
muito contente quando a gente sair só
para você pois não ligaram garambéu irã
providenciar o que vocês acham que eu
tenho uma empresa pra pensar na minha
vida profissional
contudo o fim de um animal eo eu sentia
que faltava alguma coisa na minha vida
todos os dias eram muitas deitadas com
quem já ouviu falar no caminho do
trabalho das consultoras e da leitora
sombrias bem preenchido com muitas horas
de trabalho mas hoje em dia que chegava
ao final do dia eu não estava fazendo a
diferença ou seja a minha vida é igual a
tanta gente no fundo é que se calhar a
nossa vida em trabalharmos para casa com
o pai em condomínio com a família ea
vida normal mas na vida que eu queria
ter os mutirões
eu achava e continuo a achar que sou
muito nova pra para ter essa vida e
comecei a pensar em outras notas opções
para mim claro que estamos sempre aqui o
mesmo queremos ter a carreira perfeita e
creme certo foi que eu com java disseram
muito satisfeito e queria ser mais era
muito exigente comigo mesma
an mas eu pensei que que é que ser
naquela altura eu tinha claro um passo
em frente na minha da minha vida e tenho
uma amiga que estava sendo muito ligada
em moda mais chatinha foi também acha
que estava sem miseráveis em portugal
desceu em portugal taxa para fazer uma
coisa esquisita zona de conforto desafia
tá aí então tinha muita confusão eu
conversava com o fone de ouvido um
barulho o rato eo o rap é só servir de
israel
nós temos casos aqui é normal trancados
em casa não é normal pra mim pra te ver
várias pessoas que eu estava não nunca
na vida vou conseguir fazer voluntariado
uma sitcom como aquilo mas depois eu
passava com o tempo comecei a andar a pé
é a minha visão é pensar não é mesmo um
sítio assim que eu preciso dele é mesmo
com um time completamente diferente
tomando fora daquilo que estou habituado
a ver onde eu tenho que ir foi kaká está
muito novas partes ainda mais difícil da
minha vida vai ser bom sinal mas foi sem
dúvida mais difícil que já que já tomei
foi o temor no haiti que eu voltei
automóvel não sei se vocês já ouviram
falar mas é uma organização que acredita
que o empreendedorismo é capaz de
desenvolver ser um indutor do
desenvolvimento
e eu fui a única descoberta não fazia a
menor idéia que ser com realmente foi já
sabe que é versátil que eu ia lavar a
minha própria roupa numa bacia que eu ia
aguentar uma fria mas eu nunca achei que
fosse um realmente foi um shopping
completamente quando cheguei lá eu
pensei é que eu estou há seis anos não é
possível as casas eram todas as
perguntas são muitas delas feitas em 145
osnilda num muro na rua
[Música]
eu aguento um calor que é um choque
terrível foi foi no inverno sair daqui
com um frio nós sabemos que no porto
chegaram a tentar gravar um álbum muito
muito abafado e voltava a tomar esta
decisão e foi mesmo mas muito muito
difícil fazer pelo 171 contratos sem
termo
estava eu a minha carreira estava de
fora tinha já estavam já estava há algum
tempo amanhã pode ser promovido até
pensei não tem tem mesmo que isso tem
que ser agora se não for agora não sei
quando é que vai ser e uma das coisas
que me fez tomar esta decisão vai pensar
quando for avó para divertir os nets
princesa que eu vou criar contar o que
eu vou querer contribuir para o
crescimento das outras pessoas estão as
experiências que nós temos com quem fora
da caixa e fora do campo porque é normal
que nos fazem que cheney que nos podem
ser diferente e melhor e que podem ter
alguma coisa vou partilhar e se
classificado na praia hoje não estava
aqui a falar com você e acreditem que 50
eu tenho que estar aqui contentar com o
sexto esse perfil da minha do meu
percurso esquerda centro esquerda que o
curso normal e não estaria aqui nos
treinos é muito chique eo milton
inicialmente tinha na minha carreira
profissional e não é o curso ideal isso
que eu por não ser mínimo cuidado cada
vez mais as empresas procuram pessoas
que passam apenas de frente pra com
pessoas que se adaptem é um gênio na
renovação de contrato fazer uma única
coisa que foi contratado para fazer
muitas muitas muitas coisas diferentes e
se vocês conseguirem mostrar a partida
que são capazes porque já tiveram o
governo do país porque já fizeram outras
coisas porque já fizeram obrigado
o fip atividades só vai ser um ponto a
nosso favor e não da aia ter parado seis
meses não é quebrado vocês aprendem está
fora as tarefas de voluntariado e quando
ele está fora não é fora não tem que ser
fora de portugal porque muita gente mas
não não quem não gosta do nosso adaptar
estarem fora da nossa zona de conforto e
esquece o quanto nós temos que falar
aqui hoje é esse aí nos anos conforto e
seremos os fados nós do conforto não
tinham fundos habituados melhor ou pior
para nós tem uma casa e tem uma
televisão e um comando de lavar roupa
etc entra e irem não se tem que fazer
diz não tenhamos valorizar em coisas
como por exemplo a nós quando os filmes
mendonça na nossa família concluiu neto
era natal quando tinha cinco anos e
desviam os presidentes do pai natal é
incrível
os quatro resgatados fritas as pipocas e
não ficávamos pois temos 1500 anos
eu fiz um pequeno vídeo como está a
situação de ver essas imagens e as
compras vão querer que eu estou a dizer
que chegamos num momento muito feliz nós
por nós e nós enviamos os estudiosos vez
mais uma vez por dia para ver se a
financiar estados unidos sobre uma moto
com um mundo assim tarde sem gols que
nos jornada só vamos pra casa e brindes
ela ansiedade porque a nossa família não
está enviar e sim os mais próximos de
casa também é esse que os pretendiam que
conseguiram sair da mina era tarde eo
conforto que eles ari colares não não
foi fácil viver lá de tudo mas sem
dúvida que aprendeu a valorizar muito
que o que nós temos e por exemplo
enquanto que os problemas que em semana
passam por um shopping ou mj fóruns
talento está lá o meu programa fim de
semana ele simplesmente praia e ver o
pôr-do-sol espera é das minhas coisas e
eu acho que não porque nunca fui pra
aprender o português ao poder e agora
vou pra isso ao ver o pôr do sol
prometem fazer praia você vai mesmo
falar
vejo porque o solo fique superfície ou
seja depois voltarmos e acho que essa é
uma grande chance
as pessoas votam em mim também
valorizamos pequenas coisas e crimes
cada vez mais aproveitar e e valorizamos
mesmo que o que nós temos que querer tem
que muito e não consome valdo pobreza
quatro campeões muito pobre realizada
mesmo com uma distinta mas valorizar
também por fato nós não temos que passar
por aquela realidade nós já conhecemos
uma realidade diferente mas podemos sim
ajudar os outros e construir uma
sociedade como a nossa e acho que só
pelo que nós e fico sem dúvida muito
feliz do de ter ido para lá e ter
crescido muito mesmo
nessa experiência e eu queria dizer é
que você tem que tentar perceber se
estava a sentir um desconforto é muito
fácil nós lamentarmos aplicar isto assim
não foi trabalhar sim o tentaram o que é
mais difícil de fazer disse contrário a
pensar porque estas desvantagens não
podem ajudar neste momento em que muita
gente diz que os manuscritos movimento
construir empresas e por um valor bom
das coisas e isso nós também queremos
ver em portugal a banda status que não
acontecer isso pois no momento com uma
crise nós tivemos em nossas vidas
pessoais têm que aproveitar também as
nossas pequenas crises e tentar fazer
com que essas pessoas que desenvolvam os
nossos grandes vantagens e faça então
que nos convida posso mudar o dia de
venda onde moro é fácil ganhar seis
meses depois fica uma trabalhar também
depois disso também foi mantida sem
outra vez da minha zona de conforto é
que pode ser difícil perceber como é que
alguém sente confortável lavar roupa
melancia além da água fria com ratos e
baratas não estava com ela quando seja
na minha zona de conforto e depois disso
fui para a austrália ea emel tribunal
francês - uma realidade muito diferente
da qual foi muito mais fácil da tarde
sem dúvida acho que a única coisa que eu
gosto mais ainda foi ter que tomar café
porque não há muito que até mesmo a toda
a gente toma café da manhã com trabalho
e eu acho que isso foi a defesa mais
difícil no resto foi mesmo muito fácil
adotar discretamente porque já não era
uma experiência fora já tinha tentado
animá em reforma mas também foi
importante
lá pra perceber como é que passando como
é que nós conseguimos o resultado foi
uma realizado tão diferente do passado
realizado em que a meu ver é tudo muito
pobre e muito seu desenvolvimento por
outro extremo e tão próximos e estão a
três horas de avião como é que é
possível a e é sem dúvida a nossa
capacidade de adaptação civil também
nestas nessas mudanças que saltar de um
ponto para o outro e tentarmos salvar
porque o melhor o prendemos um sikh
transportá lo para outro quando
perguntou o que eu mais gostei da
experiência que eu mais benin sendo que
foi adaptar desde o momento em que
entrei até o mesmo embora sem sombra de
dúvidas
mal cheguei e tive que me adaptar ao
amor e à mulher que o barulho é tão
cheia que é uma mudança completa do rio
além da e nunca tinha estado na ásia e
nem eu tinha ido ao brasil uma vez que a
minha família quando era muito novinha
a gente nunca tinha viajado muito por
isso mesmo uma adaptada que o calor é um
não é que eu não me dado muito próprio
mas também das coisas que mais gosto a
data foi sem dúvida a primeira é a minha
independência ou seja o temor é que ele
é muito estranho por dirigirem palavras
saber com quem está lá consegue ser nós
sentimos não liberarem 9 estamos
completamente despidos de preconceitos e
van em que compensaram não estamos mesmo
somos nós próprios comportamentos mas ao
mesmo tempo não posso ir à praia sozinha
não passa nada sozinha à noite não
passou nada nos tira que nos criaram
iraque
ou seja tudo uma uma adaptação que não é
fácil porque sempre fui muito
independente como eu muita autonomia
muito gosto de fazer conta é secular e
papai eu vou nem pensa duas vezes e
tenho que cuidar empresário não tem que
ir pra que o rapaz acorda pra poder ir
pra eu não posso ir ao supermercado
agora porque estava escuro toda a
história da célula tem que pensar sempre
antes de fazer alguma coisa
foi apenas mais uma que mais conquistou
mesmo adaptar me a que mais conquistou
entrar nessa realidade os do sul a moto
tem forman muito olhavam todas as pernas
e centra-se foi muito mais do que mais
gostou e não pensar no nós acho que pode
ir lá pensamos vamos apanhar malária ou
vender uns com casa do caminho seja
detectado o erro dizendo uma coisa uma
atitude passar uma semana já estou
completamente normal novamente aqui nos
lugares acho que o que vimos há jogadas
com vazamento já vamos tomar em que
pensam de paula no brooklin e que eu sou
muito e houve vários erros podem comer
não isso não acontece
eu tenho pavor comportamento cobras só é
um país com muitas cobras venenosas
também já não pensava nisso
por isso acho que foi uma das atrações
mais difíceis de enfrentar o medo está
sozinha na rua à noite quando um dos
animais doentes de lepra rua não esquece
completamente existe
foi uma adaptação difícil mas rápido ao
mesmo tempo e mais claro está que não é
só do timor é pouca experiência que
vocês tenham fora de portugal um estado
longe da nossa família e tem que se
adaptar à distância e não estarem perto
os aniversários no natal também vai ser
lá o natal foi bastante complicado você
está em 95
consciente o voto não querem gravar o
parou completamente sozinho ter que
fingir ou francine está tudo bem não
sofre uma queda não condicionado toda
atenção é mesmo muito difícil mas a
única certeza que os possa passar é que
vem muito mais por aí não tem nenhum por
cento de ter percebido como um quadrado
com a confiança você e teria ter vivido
essa experiência que foi durante tantas
tica e nunca esqueçam que a vida
fantástica e maravilhosa mas é muito
curto e não temos mesmo que aproveitar o
tempo que teve as vantagens que temos em
cada fase da nossa vida enquanto são
jovens ea partir disso e fazer com que
cada dia vale a pena de nós chegamos à
nossa casa adversários
hoje foi um dia diferente foi nem que eu
me esqueci pessoalmente eu reconheci os
outros acho que essa é grande é grande é
grande
no testamento nós temos que ter todos
dizem que tem que fazer valer apenas não
anda aqui a fazer nada por isso
produtos como eu posso fazer se quiserem
alguma alguns pensamentos final e sempre
foi um prazer estar aqui hoje muito
obrigado a nossa visão
[Música]
[Aplausos]